[MUSIC]
SPEAKER 1:
Hello, I'm Tessa.
SPEAKER 2:
My hat falls off a hundred times!
SPEAKER 1:
I think we did a good job.
Yeah? Yeah I think we nailed it,
for, like, dress rehearsals ...
as far as dress rehearsals go.
ETHAN HEARD: So this production is
the culimination  of a course
that the whole cast
and some of the designers
have been taking together.
As you can imagine, Princeton
students are very busy
so those four hours we're always together
and that time has been invaluable
for putting the show together.
[SINGING]
"Into the woods it’s time to go"
ETHAN HEARD: Sondheim's writing is very
detailed and precise and beautiful and deep
You have people running on, grabbing
a prop, running out,
slamming a door ... and that's
been one of the really fun challenges
of putting it together.
One of the reasons that "Into the Woods"
is such a great show for Princeton
is that there's this breadth of
18-plus fabulous characters
that are really juicy roles
for a lot of students.
One of the roles is the narrator, who
in the original Broadway production
was played by a 60-plus-year-old actor.
We wanted to reinvent the narrator.
So Kateryn, a freshman, is
playing the narrator.
She’s embodying it as a kind
of 14-year-old nerdy bookworm.
KATERYN MCREYNOLDS: When the wedding with the prince
was celebrated, Lucinda and Florinda attended.
ETHAN HEARD: We held our auditions in September
and we had a fabulous turnout.
[SINGING]
"There are giants in the sky"
"There are big tall terrible"
"Awesome scary wonderful giants"
"In the sky!"
ETHAN HEARD: We had a freshman
gentleman who came in
and on his audition form, we asked if
people are interested in particular roles,
and he was the only person who wrote,
Milky White, the cow.
At that point I wasn't sure if Milky White
was going to be played by an actor.
In the original production,
it was played by a puppet.
And he turned on some electronic
kind of pop music on his phone.
Rolled his shoulders back, and did
a really fabulous improvisational dance.
So he landed that role, no problem.
SPEAKER 3: No less than five pounds.
SPEAKER 4: Moo!
ETHAN HEARD: The beautiful
thing about this show is
it's delightful and comic and funny,
and then it asks the audience to consider
really, the dark night of the soul.
SPEAKER 5: "Maybe I shouldn't
have stolen from the giant"
SPEAKER 1: "Maybe I shouldn't
have strayed from the path"
SPEAKER 6: "Maybe I shouldn't
have attended the ball"
ETHAN HEARD: In the second act,
you see three characters
die, very quickly, back to back.
You see a group of refugees running
away to another kingdom.
You see natural disaster, you see
earthquakes, you see
the forest being ripped apart.
And we get to see these young
college students confront that
with us and for us, as our proxies.
[SINGING]
"Maybe we forgot"
ETHAN HEARD: There are two professional
designers working on the show.
Reid Thompson designed the set,
and Mio Guberinic designed costumes,
and they were able to come to campus
early on in our class
and share all their design work
with the students, which I think
really kicked off our process
in an exciting way.
We wanted to make a fresh production
so our design really updates
some of the clothing.
Our design avoids trees.
In the first act, we're in a more
comfortable, fantastical, colorful place.
And in Act II, that's really stripped away.
And we go from a theatrical world to a
more raw, real, naked scary dark place.
We play with a lot of shadows
and so we theatricalize a lot of the
magical moments in either
rear shadow play or frontal.
So we have a combination of roving lights
on the ground and flashlights
and all different kinds of cutouts.
We even have a special effect in Act II.
These big bookcases suddenly dump
hundreds of books. They tilt over
and make a pretty horrifying sound.
The first time we did that
with the students
there was genuine fear
and adrenaline in the room.
And that was really gratifying to see
how the design was inspiring the actors
and really turning them on to the story
and the experience.
I mean, one of the giants in the field
of Sondheim study is Stacy Wolf,
who founded the music theater
certificate  here
and this is really the kickoff
production of that new program
so we thought it would be delicious
if Stacy would take on the role
of the Giant herself
We had a fabulous recording session with
Stacy and Hillel, our sound designer
and she just is chewing the scenery.
She's a fabulous actor.
STACY WOLF: Where is the lad
who killed my husband?
SPEAKER 7: There is no lad here.
SPEAKER 8: We haven’t seen him.
STACY WOLF: I want the lad who
climbed the beanstalk.
SPEAKER 9: We’ll get him for you
right away. Don’t move!
ETHAN HEARD: Theater, I was saying
to the cast, is this miracle.
Someone's always bound to be sick,
or hurt, or on a late train.
When everyone is healthy and in the room
and doing the show
I think that is a miracle.
to have, you know, 30 collaborators
making a big musical like this happen.
I think the beautiful thing about
making theater and sharing theater
is coming together in a room
and breathing the same air
and listening to stories
and reconnecting with
our shared humanity.
[SINGING] "Into the woods and out of the woods,
and happy ever after ... I wish!"
"Into the Woods"